So the question is, given any variable, we're going
to introduce the variable S, and we're going to assign it
any string. Which of the pairs below are two
things where both elements of the pair are the same
exact value? So here are the choices. Check all
the choices where the first thing and the second thing
have exactly the same value. So the first thing is
S index 3, S index 1 plus 1 plus 1.
So, for any string that we choose for S, those two always have exactly the same
value, then you should check this box. Second, we have S index 0 paired
with S plus S, index 0. For the third
choice, we have S index 0 plus S index 1 paired
with S index 0 plus 1. For the
fourth choice, we have S index 1 paired with S plus the
string ity index 1. And for the fifth and final choice, we
have S index negative 1, and remember, the negative indexes go from the
back of the string, paired with S plus S index negative 1.
So for this question, you should check all the
boxes where the two items in the pair have
exactly the same value, no matter what value S
has, as long as S is a valid string.